you could have felt bad for the Mac
laptops and desktops over the last
couple of years people don't line up for
them like the iPhone or iPad but the Mac
isn't the redheaded stepchild anymore
today it's WWDC conference Apple
announced a series of design changes and
feature additions to its Mac operating
system OS 10 Yosemite and it's going to
make those Apple laptops and desktops a
lot more like the iPhone and iPad if the
design doesn't give away that Apple
wants the Mac to be more like iOS then I
don't know what does the translucent
design of menus have been brought over
and the icons are more vibrant and pop
more and check out that trashcan that is
a gorgeous trashcan you wouldn't believe
how much time we spent crafting a
trashcan I've never seen somebody so
excited about trash cans oh that would
never happen on the Mac there's also a
new Notification Center which includes
your calendar and shortcuts to other
apps hello be there and meet the new
iPhone ok not really but you can now get
cell phone calls right on your Mac
laptop or desktop you can also get text
messages too but there's even more
synergy between your iPhone iPad and Mac
now a new handoff feature lets you start
an activity on one device say an email
and then instantly pick it up on your
Mac your Mac senses when your iPhone or
iPad or nearby if it works as promised
it could save you a lot of time and
really keep your devices in sync
there lack of other features coming to
Yosemite like a new mail app and new
Safari features but the biggest takeaway
here is that I will wants all of our
devices to work better together and that
the lines between iOS and OS 10 are
really starting to blur eventually the
only thing that's going to set apart
these devices are shape and size